- Everyone's special, Dash.
- Which is another way of saying no one is.
Fine. Have it your way, Dash.
Let's pit you against your family in a BATTLE to the DEATH to see which special is the MOST special
OF ALL THE SPECIALS!
It's time.. FOR A DEATH BATTLE!!!
[intro music]
Hello Internet! Welcome to FILM THEORY;
The only show that can monologue longer than a villain in a superhero movie.
- You sly dog! You got me monologuing, I can't believe it.
Today I'm covering what's perhaps the most beloved movie in Pixar's lineup: The Incredibles.
A film that probably earned that title because a lot of you watching saw it when you were kids;
a fact that, in retrospect, is a bit alarming considering what the movie's really about.
I mean, for a family-friendly film you have a villain that actually kills people,
a wife that suspects that her husband is cheating,
and repeated deaths by engine turbine.
I've always thought that it had a weird message too: where Buddy,
the young fan boy, who's shunned by his hero,
pulls himself up by his bootstraps to become a billionaire weapons designer,
using his genius intellect to create devices that give him the power of a superhero himself.
Which honestly is a story arc that should be praised.
I gotta say as the one who felt ostracized throughout school, I totally relate to this guy's story.
He should be a good role model! He didn't give up,
he used his innate abilities to get better, to get to the position where he wanted to be.
But instead, in this movie has an inferiority complex and becomes a sociopathic killer.
- You mean you killed off real heroes so that you could pretend to be one?!
- Oh, I'm real, and I did it without your precious gifts!
Your 'Oh-so-special' powers.
Ay, hey Pixar, I totally feel what you're going for here, but seriously. Intelligence should be a real superpower.
But NOPE! Not The Incredibles!
And then the rest of the film treats him like a joke, until he dies a gruesome death,
and the heroes are all solidified as the ones who are born with their innate abilities.
Clearly, this movie believes that some people are just more super than others.
And since you killed off the character I most relate to, MOVIE,
I'm going full supervillain and giving you a dose of your own medicine.
Which super IS the most super in the Parr family?
Who is the most powerful Incredible?
Is it the speed demon Dash?
The quiet psychic Violet?
The flexible Elastigirl?
Or the brute force of Mr. Incredible?
There's also the baby Jack-Jack, the big wild card in the family, whose powers seemed to vary from
setting himself on fire to changing to different materials, you could say he's a regular...
Jack-Jack of all trades (ba dum tss)
But knowing how Hollywood storytelling works and based on the fact that the trailers are already playing all this up,
It probably means he's gonna be revealed to be the most powerful character in Incredibles 2
so I'm knocking him out of the competition.
In the meantime though, place your bets, ladies and gentlemen, because four Incredibles enter,
one Incredible leaves! (Evil laughter)
Man, I really am starting to sound like Syndrome...
-  Everyone can be super! And when everyone's super... (evil chuckling)
- ...No one will be.
First things first: if you want to talk about raw strength, then you have to talk about Mr. Incredible.
Even if Bob Parr has put on a few pounds since retiring from his superhero days
he is still a hunk of muscle, tossing around cars the same way most of us would toss around a frisbee.
I guess if he were really throwing the car like I throw a frisbee it would mean he would throw the car,
And immediately karate chop down into the ground and then roll around on its edge in a direction completely
opposite the thing I was trying to throw it at. Just rubbing the shame in my face as it rolls..
But where we really see him start to push his powers to their limits is when he halts a train traveling at full speed
right in its tracks. To figure out how much force he needs to stop that train, we need to know two things:
The train's deceleration, how quickly he was able to bring that train to a halt, and the train's mass,
Calculating the train's mass is a bit difficult because for the brief moments that the train is actually seen
on-screen, we never see how many train cars there are. However, with a bit of historical research,
we can actually come up with a pretty good guess on how many train cars there were, how much they weighed,
and how fast the train would have to have been moving. In order to determine the mass of each railway car,
we can compare it to a similar railway car in the real world.
In the movie, we see Bob reading a copy of the Metroville Tribune, which when you zoom in real close
shows that the second half of this movie is set in the year 1962.
The train stopping scene happens in the movie's opening moments before a 15-years-later flash-forward,
meaning that that scene with the Train happens in 1947.
Details also point to the city of Metroville being based on Chicago:
the font and name of the newspaper make it look like a tribute to the famous "Chicago Tribune"
and Chicago is a metropolitan city that had a booming economy during the time period of the movie.
More importantly, Chicago is also famous for its L-train - short for elevated train,
that served as a citywide Rapid Transit System since 1892.
Based on the year the movie takes place and the appearance of the cars, they appear to be
the Metroville equivalent of the Chicago
L Train's Steel 5000 Series cars
which were in service from 1947 to 1985
We also know based on historical research that the 5000-series of car had an unloaded weight of
93 000 pounds plus another 14 688 pounds from the weight of all the passengers inside and yes I
calculated that using the average weight of a person in
1950 which I might notice over 20 pounds lighter than the average weight for a person in the year
2000! Hey, you have to account for everything when it comes to historical accuracy and also our ever expanding waistline
Lastly the length of the Train in the scene
We're able to count eleven visible railway cars and based on everything we know about elevated trains in the 1940s
Which is a surprisingly large amount after doing this episode the Train probably wouldn't be any longer than that in fact
It was uncommon for trains to be longer than six cars during commuter hours way back then all of that gives us a grand total
of 1 184 568 pounds for the mass of the train that is
592 tons. Mister incredible certainly has a lot of work to do and work
He does he brings that train from 55 miles per hour to a screeching
halt in just under ten seconds nine point nine seconds if we want to be exact do that to a
592 ton train he'd need to exert a force of 1 333 000 Newtons
That's the equivalent of 299 670 pounds
of force just for comparison a study of seventy boxers found that elite level fighters punch with an average of
776 pounds of force with the strongest one ever not being able to reach
1 300 pounds of force Bob's punch by comparison would be
230 times stronger than that they don't call him mr.
Incredible for nothing and with that one million three hundred thirty three thousand newtons of force is our number B's
Next up is Helen Parr aka mom aka Elastigirl
Measuring Elastigirl strength is a bit trickier here since she's not really about raw strength, but rather raw stretch
We never really get to see her stretched to her limits
Haha, but we do get to see how flexible her abilities are but whom Ching alright. I'm done with the puns
She has a parachute mode boat mode hovercraft mode limbo mode shield offspring from oncoming homing missile
Explosion mode up completely shielding the kids from an explosion of a homing missile
Yikes if her body is able to go full Groot and repel the force of explosion like that
Protecting what's inside it must be pretty strong and based on her passing out in the aftermath of the explosion
It's pushing her powers to their limits, so that is the scene we're gonna analyze
But just how strong is she let's look at the missiles
We don't actually see any other aircraft in the vicinity
So it looks like these are gonna be surface-to-air missiles Sam's as opposed to air-to-air missiles
But how powerful are they well when it comes to surface-to-air missiles the explosive yield will ultimately depend on the warhead
It's carrying, but faster usually means more powerful
I mean the fastest missiles in the world's our ICBMs, which can reach speeds of over Mach 15
15 times the speed of sound and they're usually designed to carry nuclear warheads
scary thought
anyway from the way that the missiles appear to only barely out speed the plane we can assume that they're probably moving and close to
The same rate now a typical commercial jet would be able to hit speeds of around 600 miles per hour which is
subsonic less than the speed of sound
Not even Mach 1, and we never actually see Helens plane cross any sound barriers
Even as she's trying to avoid these missiles so that means that the missiles must be moving pretty slowly
Currently the slowest and typically weakest surface-to-air missiles used by the US military
Still hit a speed of around Mach two and a half
Which means I guess syndromes weapons budget was more focused on building killer robots
And not so much on buying anti-aircraft missiles information on the subject is a bit hard to find and digging around for it has
Undoubtedly put me back on top of several government watch lists there goes my trusted traveler past
I worked a year to get but out of all the missiles used by the US military the slowest one is the
rim-116 rolling airframe missile
Ram a missile delivering a warhead with an explosive yield
equivalent of forty seven point two seven nine mega joules or just around twenty four point nine pounds of TNT
But here's where things get even more complicated in the scene we see not one not two
But three missiles also Elastigirl isn't even the first thing the explosion hits impacting two plane before even hitting her also also
We have to consider the fact that Elastigirl isn't at the epicenter of the explosion when the missiles go off this all?
matters because what we think of as an
Explosion is basically just a shockwave that gets weaker and weaker as it move away from the epicentre and this drop-off happens
exponentially so this time we're just gonna have to do some rough estimations if we estimate that the planes main body or
Fuselage is 10 centimeters thick aluminum standard for a typical Boeing aircraft
And we use what we know about the impact strength of aluminum and estimate elastic girls distance from the initial explosion at around 3 meters
based on the size and shape of the cabin and where we see the missile impact the aircraft the last girl's body is absorbing a
Whopping three million five hundred and ten thousand pounds of force that is more than 10 times
As much force as we calculated for mr.
Incredible to stop that moving train ladies and gentlemen we have ourselves a new front runner and a new definition of girl power
And a new definition of wonderful Cale stop up next is flash
I mean - the speedster in the family who knows though
Maybe Incredibles - will feature reverse - complete with a yellow costume
They could even completely rip off the flesh and recreate that time that the flash was shot with a fat ray
Kidnapped and then put on display as the thousand-pound blunder like some sort of freak show ah you get it cuz he's obese now
Yikes the 60s were a very different time anyway - demonstrates his SuperSpeed a lot throughout the movie
But believe it or not
Greatest feat of speed that we actually see him pull off is when he rushes up to his teacher's desk to place a thumbtack on
The seat and rushes back to his seat
Hey, dude calm down why you freaking out? It's just a prank bro. Don't be a prick about it
Get it prick cuz it's a thumbtack
Anyway, the teacher determined to catch - and the act has a surveillance camera record the incident and for a single frame of the video
We see - moving if we assume that the video is recording at 24 frames per second as most video cameras did back in
1962 that would mean - was covering a distance of about 4 meters in just one
twenty-fourth of a second that translates to a speed of 96 meters per second or
214 miles per hour but does that give - the ability to topple his mother strength earlier we saw mr.
incredible stop a speeding el train, but could he stop -
Running towards him at top speed
But what's most impressive about - isn't his speed so much as it is his acceleration
the fastest sports cars on earth take around 2
seconds to go from 0 to 60 miles per hour - is able to go from 0 to
200 14 miles per hour and stop
And then reverse his direction to get back to his seat again in just a tiny
fraction of a second literally less than the blink of an eye I ran the numbers and he's accelerating at a rate of
9216 meters per second square to figure out whether dash can actually topple his father we use one of my favorite equations of all time
On the show flaw or force equals mass times acceleration has solved for the force that - is creating
We just found his acceleration now multiply that by the average mass for a ten-year-old boy
Which is about 72 pounds or 32 point five kilograms, and we find out that Dash's speedy little legs are generating
299 thousand five hundred Newton's of thrust the equivalent of
67,000 three hundred pounds of force which is more thrust than the engine of a Boeing 747
commercial jetliner with force and speed like that perhaps his most amazing super
The fact that he's able to get away with that tack prank
He should be causing a massive wind that sends papers at the very least flying throughout classroom anyway at just under
300 thousand Newtons he's still a million
Newtons away from the raw strength of his father to match the force of his dad - would need to put on a few pounds
a few
Hundred pounds in fact starting with that 1.3 million Newton threshold we calculated for dear old dad and dividing by dashes acceleration
he'd need to weigh in at 141 kilograms or
310 pounds to tackle his father and way more than that to punch through his mother's elasticity
837 pounds or a whopping
380 kilograms, where is a good politically incorrect flash fat ray when you need it?
And then there was one 14 year old violet the bashful
Shy girl, who wants nothing more than to reject her superpowers and be normal or self now
She's a tricky one since her powers aren't physical like anyone else in her family first the girl who wants to hide from the world
Can appropriately enough turn invisible but more to our purposes?
She can create force fields capable of blocking pretty much anything
And you can't have a force field without the word force the exact measurement
We've been using to compare the family we find out about ninety minutes into the movie that violets force fields can easily deflect bullets
Fusing the performance of a standard-issue m16 rifle as reference with a
960 meter per second muzzle velocity 4.0 two grams mass per bullet and an estimated
Stopping distance of point zero one meters the protective bubble. She's creating is acting with
83,000
288 pounds of force
370 thousand Newtons that alone puts her ahead of her brother when it comes to raw strength
But it's not even close to the full extent of her force fields power you have more power than you realize
Don't think and don't worry if the time comes you'll know what to do
Hey saying
You're good in the final battle against syndromes aamna droid version 10 she pulls out her
strongest force field to protect - from the giant robot the omnijoin 10 is a metal sphere with a hole thickness of about half a
meter and a diameter of about thirty nine point six meters
And we know this by comparing it to the size of the buildings we see it next to where it appears to be about 12
Stories high accounting for the fact that omnijoin appears to be mostly hollow inside the metal part alone would have a volume of
2,400 two cubic meters that amount of Steel would have a mass of 1 point 8 5 times 10 to the 7th kilograms or
40 million seven hundred eighty thousand pounds Newton's third law you know the one that says that every action has an equal and opposite reaction
Tells us that if violet is supporting an object that weighs 40 million pounds
Then her force field has to exert an upward force of 40 million pounds
181 million three hundred ninety-eight thousand four hundred seventy six thousand Newtons that is nearly
180 times the force that her father used to stop that train and over ten times what her mom withstood in the plane
Explosions, and that's not even calculating the fact that the robot is slamming its body into the force field which means that we have
Unequivocally found our strongest incredible it is dear old dad
Yeah
the force field would make violet the strongest incredible by an
Enormous margin if it weren't for the fact that several seconds later when violet passes out from the effort of holding up that object we
See her father step in to save the day by lifting up the exact same omnijoin and unlike violet
He's able to sustain wait without passing out from the efforts, but that's impossible
I hear you saying I said it too when I was researching this episode violet has to be the strongest from our calculations mr.
Incredible holding up that robot takes more than a hundred
Times the amount of force that we saw him use to stop the train at the start of the movie
It's not like he wasn't trying when it came to stopping that train
He knew that there are a lot of lives at stake
And he barely managed to stop it before it fell off the rails
So how is it that we see him so much stronger at the end of the movie especially?
When we know that this is after 15 years of him being out of service as a super well
Maybe this heroic feat of strength is chalked up to the greatest superpower of them all
family
Gag me cut it out with your family kumbaya nonsense eeeh hippies
But seriously seeing his children's lives at stake Bob leaps to their defense and provides the most monumental
Demonstration of strength that we see throughout the entire movie, this is actually known as
Hysterical strength display of extreme strength by humans beyond what's believed to be normal usually occurring when people are in life-and-death
Situations, this is most commonly associated with stories of parents lifting vehicles to save their kids in this case
It's Bob Parr lifting a giant Death droid to save his kids scientific evidence to prove it is scarce since as you can imagine
It's a bit hard to test this sort of thing in a lab
Hey, we're gonna put your kid under a car go lift it
But it is theoretically possible believed to be tied to the body increasing adrenaline production in times of crisis so violet is
Definitely number one unless parental instincts come into play, and you know what that seems like a fitting climax for a movie
That's ultimately more about family bonds than it is about
superpowers
sometimes it takes the family to save the day and even though Dash and violet might not be as strong as their dad in a
Way they were indirectly responsible for his greatest feat of strength
And that's Disney Pixar's The Incredibles
Your favorite childhood movie with the moral of you have to be boring special in order to be special
Sorry
Syndrome your super intelligence and ceaseless work ethic don't merit you becoming a super
Luckily real life doesn't have to work that way work hard enough, and you can gain yourself super abilities case-in-point our sponsor for the day
Skillshare an online learning community with more than
17,000 classes and film business and writing basically
It's all the skills that you need if you're thinking of becoming a super youtuber or really any other modern day career for that matter
Finding good reliable and most importantly useful resources to teach yourself online is surprisingly difficult these days
I mean you don't want to fall into the trap of Jake Paul's how to be a youtuber program
Which I kid you not is a real thing that is really unhelpful
So Skillshare solves that problem by giving you access to online
Educators who really have the skills and want to help you succeed true story I had to teach myself
Everything when I first started on YouTube and videos like the ones that I found on Skillshare
Such as editing and Premiere Pro for beginners were the only ways I was able to get better because there are just some things that
You don't know that you don't know and honestly
These sorts of videos are how I continue to teach myself to this day and short classes like skill shares creative direction for drone
building and DIY
Cinematography are helping me learn more skills more modern skills that allow me to be more creative in my videos
And I know I talked a lot about video
But it's not just video skills share has everything from search engine
Optimization to website building to mobile app design 3d printing, Microsoft Excel basically
It's all the things that schools should be teaching you for a job in the modern workplace
But are too far behind the times to cover Sokol skills shares their to fill in the gaps and not only a skill share more
useful than most school courses
It's also way more affordable with an annual subscription
Costing less than ten dollars a month and with this special offer you can get the first three months of skill share for just
99 cents it was originally supposed to be through the month of January
But because you guys are so special and because this video happens only come on. They're extending it until February 15
What better gift to give your loved one for Valentine's Day than the gift of knowledge GT Live merged technically?
But that will be on sale until next week so
Skillshare sign up at the link that you see on screen or it's at the top line of the description
Skl sh film theorists. You don't actually know that that is a crappy URL
You're never gonna remember that Oh, sh e I'm gonna remember to put that up in the URL bar
It's in the top line of the description sign up
It's 99 cents to try it for three months teach yourself a couple new skills like drone filmmaking which is tough
Just not gonna find that stuff anywhere else so remember friends life isn't like The Incredibles
You can work to achieve what you want and places like Skillshare are out there to help again one last time in
Crediting the description since not even super memory will help you remember the huge block of link text you see on screen right now
but you know what you can remember the fact that this was all just a theory a
film theory and
commence learning